we are pleased to be joined this morning
by Frank Oz welcome thank you and I
can't wait to see a Garry Shandling dr.
knife is good wait and so it is this you
know it's so incredible to see sort of
behind the scenes when you look at
computer-generated images now these days
talking to you about how in this film
got a crouch down low the things you've
got to do you've never had this many
puppeteers in one room why'd you decide
to do that well actually was a Victoria
the bombs idea she was she's a producer
and my wife and she saw us guys how we
round around and still cared about each
other and screwed each other all over
but still love each other and Jeff never
seen this kind of a work atmosphere and
she wanted to get it out there
that's the big story in this documentary
is is the work atmosphere and and you're
continuing affection for Jim Henson who
you worked for all those years yeah it's
it's it's not a continuing connection I
mean if you see our documentary you can
have a sense of what what was inside him
is now inside us it is you know and what
was that exactly I think that was
incredibly hard work and while you're
working on stuff you didn't even like
you're still having fun that and long
work and also being collaborative and no
ego only working for the excellence of
the product and trying to screw each
other over we all try to break each
other up and upstage each other at the
same time you know so but fairness I can
go on about Jim but he was a singular
individual do you know what surprised me
the most the Muppets were very much a
part of my childhood but you say this
wasn't written for children well good
for adults I what do I know about kids
what do you know about kids
we'll have three but I'm still learning
I mean I I when I was a kid I didn't
know what I wanted how do adults know
what kids want yeah we never we've never
worked toward kids we've only we've only
done adult stuff we're doing I mean
we're just playing around as adults
that's all we are and documentary you'll
see that that which is a muppet guys
talking dot-com the only place you can
get this documentary
Muppet guys talking about calm by doing
a good job right you're doing a very
good month guys talking calm because
we're not releasing it and the big
company it's just gonna be it's just us
one of the fascinating things I learned
is that you actually one of the things
you had to do with each character was
come up with a backstory for them no I
didn't have to but you felt you needed
to I do I absolutely do
yeah you have to know who Grover is I
have to have some sense of who they are
because otherwise they're just surface
characters yeah otherwise they wouldn't
touch you yeah if there's nothing deep
inside them they're not going to touch
what's deep inside you yeah you know so
it's it's just me who does that and some
of the guys do it also but I do a lot of
it I did a lot of I haven't performed
for about ten years I've been directing
stuff right do you do you have a do you
have a favorite of your Muppet
characters I'm just curious
I think Grover and Fozzie are more more
like me and and there's an ease there
but they're they're all parts of me all
parts of everybody else
you know it's I mean but the thing about
these characters you know they wouldn't
exist if people if we didn't work the
way we did
no because they wouldn't exist that way
and that that work is is just
collaborative there's no ego whatsoever
there's no politics well we work like
hell and we just have a what was it that
it was Jim it was all genuine and Jim
never told us what to do you never said
anything you never told me once right he
just was himself and we learned
throughout osmosis and just followed him
and he was but he was not a general who
who saw the war from the rooftop from
the mountaintop he was leading the
charge 15 feet ahead of us always and
did much more I mean it in the
documentary we have so many secrets that
nobody knows we've never let people know
before and there's some of Jim that you
wouldn't believe you know so if Jim
really understood the characters you
have been pretty critical of Disney for
not sort of getting these no it's weird
the the what's up with Disney the
trouble with print is they can't print
tone yeah and so my tone was not
combative my tone is hopeful because
Disney really wants to
good job they're really doing the very
best they can and to people especially a
Kyle and Debbie really get it there
they're terrific in the Muppets to do
but there are people at in the TV and
motion picture area the thing is what
they don't understand is that one can't
just write for the Muppets
there are performance we've been with
Jim for decades yeah and they're not
being part of the process right those
people those Baretta in here Dave goals
they are brilliant they know the soul I
can't I just wish they would be asked to
be part of the creation and that's what
would make a success for Disney really
so I had nothing against Disney Jim
wanted to go to Disney right absolutely
you know so so in other words you're
saying that the actors are part of the
characters in effect they need to be
consult there if we actually the the
characters could not be popular
without us down below we know each other
for so many years you can't just bring a
new guy in right you just can't do it
and it's also weird cuz it's like buying
a thoroughbred and not letting them race
yeah thank you so much for being with us
this morning I thank you measure you can
download the documentary right now just
go to Muppet guys talking com I love you
I love you coming out I love you
[Laughter]